When the old blood was found
it must have been thought a miracle.
They called it "the blood of the Gods"
and rightly so
for if you injected it into your veins
you would no longer be afflicted by the weaknesses of the flesh.
it follows that a city built upon this blood would become mighty indeed
and so it was with Yharnam.
The supply of the blood was controlled by the Healing Church
and the Church became the most powerful of all.
But the blood was foul, infected.
Those who've taken the old blood began transforming into hideous beasts
and eventually, the Church could keep the scourge a secret no longer.
Fearing the populace itself
they retreated into Cathedral Ward
and devised a plan to fight back.
The Church Hunters were that plan.
The hunters in white specialized in experimental blood ministration
for the Church continued to use the old blood.
Albeit now, with fear in their hearts.
The hunters in black were a little different,
their role was to violently purge this town of the beastly scourge.
Beasthood was a cancer
and with their surgical white gloves
the black Church Hunters would rip the beasthood from the hearts of the yharnamites.
They were known to dispose the victims,
even potential victims,
before signs of sickness had even manifested themselves.
Their black attire inspired fear in the hearts of the Yharnamites
for if they decided that you had the beast within you,
then it was so.
But the beast lies dormant within us all.
And ironically, the clerics transformed into the most terrifying beasts.
"Father" is a title used for clerics in a foreign land
and the Healing Church knew no such rank.
An outsider, Father Gascoigne, joined the ranks of the Black Church Hunters
Perhaps he, like many others, was sick
and needed treatment.
Perhaps he saw the miracles that the Church was performing.
Actual miracles
that could've inspired a new faith in the men.
Or perhaps it was thirst for blood that drew him here
for Gascoigne turned out to be a truly capable hunter.
A fine addition to the ranks of the Church.
Gascoigne was partnered with another,
an older hunter, by the name of Henryk.
Capable, beyond his years.
This old man was easily recognizable in his unique yellow garb.
It's description tells us that they were a fierce and gallant duo,
but also that their partnership led to Henryk's tragically long life.
He must have been very old indeed
to be tragically so.
Perhaps Gascoigne's access to the Church
granted Henryk access to the old blood
and it's possible that the miraculous blood granted him life, beyond his years.
Who knows what that can do to a man...
Together, Henryk and Gascoigne were a part of the effort to purge Yharnam of the scourge
Just two more hunters doing "what hunters must"
for the good of the city, of course.
Gascoigne even found love outside the Church's walls within Ccentral Yharnam
A woman named Viola.
Blonde and favouring a bright red brooch.
Perhaps the jewel was a gift from a hunter.
Imagine being a man of Yharnam during this time
put your yourself in this city.
As a good yharnamite would,
you join the nightly hunt with your brothers.
Fighting against the scourge.
You lock your woman and children safely at home
with incense at their doors to ward away the beasts.
You fight alongside the Black Church Hunters,
though, this men of the Church are watching you at all times
for any signs of the plague.
You fight alongside those who would kill you if they had to.
In time, Viola fell pregnant.
Soon after,  Gascoigne left the Healing Church.
Perhaps he had something more important to him, now.
"Who... are you? I dont know your voice."
"But I know that smell."
"Are you a hunter?"
Familly must have pulled him away from the Church
and on the night of our unending hunt
we find this young girl alone in her family's home.
"Please, will you look for my mum?"
"Daddy never came back from the hunt, and she went to find him, but now she's gone, too..."
"I'm all alone... and scared..."
We're looking for a woman with a red brooch
and a man garbed in black.
Imagine being Gascoigne at this point in the story.
An ex-hunter of the Healing Church,
he still wears the tattered black garb that shows how faithfully he served the Church in their hunt.
And tonight, the hunt is worse than any night before it.
Tonight, the line between man and beast is blowed.
The beast-men of Yharnam cry for death to their ministers
if they see you wearing their minister's garb.
This is the exact same thing Gascoigne was wearing.
It's unclear exactly what happened in the tomb of Oedon
but here we find Father Gascoigne,
surrounded by the corpses of fellow yharnamites
Hacking them to pieces,
completely lost to his thirst for blood.
On a rooftop nearby
we find his wife,
dead.
"My mum wears a red jeweled brooch. It's so big and beautiful. You won't miss it."
"Oh, I mustn't forget."
"If you find my mum, give her this music box."
"It plays one of daddy's favorite songs."
"And when daddy forgets us we play it for him so he remembers."
"Mum's so silly, running off without it!"
"A small music box recieved from a young Yharnam girl."
"Plays a song shared by her mother and father."
"Inside the lid is a small scrap of paper, perhaps an old message.
"Two names can be made out, however faintly,"
"Viola and Gascoigne."
When we play their song,
the husband recoils an agony
Gascoigne is losing himself to the beastly scourge
he wants to forget,
but the music reminds him of his wife,
his children,
his city
his humanity,
his dead wife.
His broken city,
his despair.
His wife is likely dead as his hand
for she didn't have their music box to remind him of who he was
as she had done many times before.
Gascoigne is beyond saving
and you end his suffering.
It almost sound as if his last words are "forgive me".
"Forgive me!"
We don't have the heart to give a child her dead's mother brooch.
Instead, we send her to Oedon Chapel.
She can't stay in this house alone
for neither her mother nor her father is coming back for her.
Better to send her to a safe place.
"Hello miss hunter."
"Still can't find my mum?"
"Oh, okay. I can wait."
"But isn't there something I can do?"
"Maybe mum and dad are stuck out there,"
"waiting for me to come and find them."
"What do you think, miss hunter?"
We send her to Oedon Chapel
"Yes okay, thank you miss hunter! I love you almost as much as mum and dad, and grandad!"
She never appears there.
Trace the path she would have taken
imagine this little girl creeping through a sewer filled with crawling corpses and carrion crows.
To run past it all and come so close the chapel only to spy this ting at the end of the tunnel.
It eats the little girl
and after your revenge,
you find the bloodied white ribbon upon its remains.
"Oh..."
"you haven't by chance... seen my little sister, have you?"
Someone did come back for the little girl
turns out, Gascoigne had two daughters and you just sent one to her death.
"I told her to look after the house, but she's run off somewhere."
"She's still quite small, and wears a big white ribbon. Have you seen her out there anywhere?"
"Oh, how did this happen..."
"Why would she ever go outside?"
"At least... I'll have something to remember her by."
The truly sad thing is
a friend of the family was waiting at Oedon tomb arround this time.
The one the littlest daughter calls "grandad".
He could've met the youngest daughter there
had the pig not consumed her in the tunnel.
Instead, Henryk goes mad here in this place
Perhaps he discovered that someone killed his friend
or perhaps, since the littlest daughter calls him "grandad",
he discovered the corpse of his daughter,
Viola.
"Perfect timing"
"I must warn you..."
"...not to go near the tomb below Oedon Chapel in the Cathedral Ward."
"Henryk,"
"an old hunter, has gone mad."
"And he's my mark..."
When we arrive, we're already too late.
As with Gascoigne, loss pushes Henryk over the edge.
We've seen that hunters turn into terrible beasts,
so the hunter must become the hunted.
"That wasn't necessary of ya."
But you have my thanks."
"We made it with our lives... You're not bad at all."
"You must have killed Gascoigne as well then."
"He was falling apart... I'm sure it had to be done."
But try to keep your hands clean..."
"The Hunter should hunt Beasts."
"Leave the hunting of Hunters, to me."
Gascoigne killed his wife.
We killed Gascoigne.
Henryk tried to kill us, so Eileen killed Henryk.
The last surviving daughter throws herself off a ledge
upon receiving her sister's bloodied ribbon.
And the bloodline of Gascoigne ends here.
However, somewhere in another hunt, perhaps,
you never spoke to the littlest daughter.
She never went looking for her parents,
she never travelled down this tunnel.
She stayed home until her sister returned
and they huddled together until morning came.
"I won't be afraid. I know, I do."
"The morning always comes."